and the brightest day and the blackest
night no evil shall escape my light let
those who worship evil's might beware my
power green lantern's light welcome to
the weekly pool we are the podcast from
a dc fanatica marvel fanatic and david i
still don't know what he reads
that may be one of the greatest intros
ever made
i am comic story and well i'm infected
crow of comic story and check out my
channel channel at backslash comic story
and why don't you guys introduce
yourselves rob you go first so we'll
keep this in order we'll keep it going
compete with that give me something
i got nothing to compete with that my
name's rob and i'm from marvel explain
where i explain everything marvel comics
related where's your oath frog
i don't have an oath man i don't have an
oath i don't have i don't have a green
lantern shirt i don't have any green
lantern rings i have no paraphernalia to
go along with my comic book stuff
and uh i'm i'm david soon to be from
comics reviews
david is launching his own channel we
are teaching him in the ways of the
green lanternos
and youtube and youtube
oh man all right all right so
we're done with the podcast guys that's
it for the record
rob was like can you do the intro and
i'm like i got this planned just you're
gonna be so off your game it's gonna be
great yeah after that intro like yeah
we're gonna thanks for listening guys
we'll uh we'll catch you guys later
for anybody wondering i have the green
lantern ring for full power this is my
uniform when i go to owa and this is my
blue lantern ring to juice my green
lantern rings yes
for those of you who are unaware and not
in the know the dc lore
blue lantern rings really can't do
anything but if they're in the vicinity
of a green lantern ring they overcharge
them
huh
god man see all i remember about green
lanterns is they had a green lantern
ring that they had to charge for the
giant green lantern
yeah they still have that pocket
universe
yeah and then there's
is that a link to or does that those
batteries get charged the pocket
batteries link to the giant battery in
noaa ah it's like a portable charger and
they eventually have to go back to oh
and charge up their portable batteries
i think i should always wait to recall
the cops you know
come check in don't know what you've
been doing hal but i hear earth's about
to die again
okay so on this podcast um we're going
to talk about a few things one of course
we're going to talk about days of future
past which is something that has to be
discussed because i think we finally got
around
the movie and our opinions on the
changing of the plot
yes because i think at this point
everybody's seen the movie now um
we're also going to be talking about the
update to original sin issue number
three uh the dc features end event the
uh
rumors of dc jumping ahead five years in
april and and so on and so forth also
we're going to talk about the justice
league movie casting uh the changes
they've done because i actually don't
know
about that
i don't know about matt fleck
oh oh yeah
little model girl i got for wonder woman
we don't need muscles on an amazonian
screen
wow see i don't all i knew is they cast
ben affleck as uh as batman the guy from
um
uh man of steel is coming back as
superman yep and i i had no idea what
other casting choices they got oh i'm
gonna have so much fun
apparently the casting choice for wonder
woman they're they're going to try to
get ripped but i cannot no didn't happen
they already started filming
no they've already started that was the
theory that was what everyone they're
like oh she's a pretty girl and if she
can put muscle mass on she can pull off
one you know what let's just start we're
gonna we're go i'm gonna run on my
tangent we're just gonna start with just
the same casting choices all right we're
gonna start with the movies and then
we'll go into the dc comics stuff we're
going to start with the okay so they see
okay so we got we got the guy from man
of steel henry cavill cavill whatever
his name is whatever he he did a great
job of superman the the changes to
superman were not him and that's where
we're going to go with this movie stuff
the changes in how they reflected our
comic book counterparts they weren't him
he was a great superman the movie itself
had problems in my opinion but uh then
we got ben affleck like his batman
okay
i mean the guy was daredevil and did a
horrible job with that he ruined that
franchise but that's what i'm worried
about man i'm worried about who's going
to screw up i i don't know if he
necessarily did a terrible job i think
it was the writing that he created
which is why because ben affleck is a
good actor in some movies
you know he's not he's not the guy from
uh
uh what's it called like reindeer games
and stuff like that he's not that guy
he's he's had a lot of really good
movies lately
now they pulled off a random chick to be
wonder woman and she's tiny she's a tiny
girl but the running theory was well she
can get ripped in time to be wonder
woman they started filming she has not
put an ounce of muscle on
okay
so on set she's unless they're doing
like
five years later i don't know do it live
and we'll fix it in post yeah
muscles
we'll 3d track muscles on her yeah but
here's here's here's where i don't
understand dc and why like why
marvel has literally written the
playbook on how we want comic book
movies they've written it
we want a giant continuity we want every
movie to not be related but related you
know like
first was it a winter soldier you can
watch that movie by yourself but if
you've watched everything else you
understand so much more
yeah you do you really do why can't we
do that with dc no instead instead we're
gonna have the dark knight returns and
now here's my opinion on that one
everyone's like well that's the nolan
verse that all of us made everything
realistic and it did make everything
realistic but what they didn't do in the
nolan verse is go anywhere else
gotham has always been slightly grounded
in reality while the rest of the dc
universe is like metahumans and insane
and you could you could have taken the
nolan verse and then just taken all of
these movies and put them between two
and three before batman's retiring and
moving to freaking like italy what the
[ __ ] what's up with that
okay anyway
you could have put everything else
between these and the nolan verse would
have been incorporated but no dc wasted
seven years on dark christopher nolan's
batman movies
why okay okay but all right i'm gonna go
for i'm gonna go to bat for christopher
nolan on this all right if they made
other dc movies like christopher nolan's
batman movies they would be amazing like
if they oh yeah if they had like
superman and you have like a gritty down
version of superman so here's the kicker
here's what makes no sense so
christopher nolan did the dark knight
series that batman trilogy is
stand-alone and on its own and to kick
it all off it's only a few years old
we're not talking about like the tim
burton universe that is like burton
verse from forever ago we're talking
about a few few years old he then
produced or got he had some kind of
credit on man of steel to make it that
darker tone
so you're already starting to line up
man of steel with the design and feel
that you've given dark knight
now everybody was excited about it yeah
now we have the man of steel 2 which is
now batman vs superman
we've recast batman new batman new
everything we got superman coming back
we got a new wonder woman we've got
cyborgs showing up that seems to be an
okay casting but here's here's where it
blows my mind so this is dawn of justice
and then we're filming the justice
league movie following it right
they still are casting green lantern and
the flash and all this other stuff
the the cw is running and
it's good i watch eight marvel agents of
shield the aerial tv show is 10 times
better they know what they're doing
and they're now launching a flash show
to go in line with the aero show we've
cast green arrow we've cast the flash
and while we're not 100
on board with the flash being like 10
years younger and an intern instead of
being barry allen 30 you know in his
career we've cast him
so why are we going to launch that tv
show and then like a year later recast
the flash and put him in the movie
yeah see that's one of the things that i
liked about the the whole agents of
shield element of the marvel cinematic
universe agents of shield is i mean in
terms of like production value it's just
not very good like the acting is not
very good like death lock was pretty
much like the only major super kind of
powered person that you saw i mean
they tried they tried too much to go
whedon on it we didn't wanted to create
this inner universe and as much as i
liked the first 12 episodes that
alienated most of the the public who
watched it because we didn't have death
clock we didn't have superpowers we had
a cia group in a world with superheroes
where all they ever did was say well hey
i know thor
yeah exactly exactly and here's here's
the deal what i thought would be what i
was hoping and what i thought would be
really cool about the agents of shield
storyline or the the show is that we
would get a chance to see characters and
superheroes that just weren't very big
yeah they're just like we're big the d
line up the c line you know exactly
they're saying that they're gonna do
more of that in season two
and then you know and i i will i will
somewhat
season one of arrow was horrendous
i hated season one the character of
arrow killed people he didn't go by the
name green arrow he didn't have a mask
the whole entire plot was off the wall
all it was was him trying to get his own
revenge it was nothing like green arrow
it was just a guy with a bow and a green
hood that's all it freaking was
season two 100 redeemed to that series
it brought in other villains it brought
in a code on the arrow he had the arrow
cave he had his proper sidekicks he got
his mask everything became green arrow
in one season and marvel agents of
shield has been announced for season two
they can do that still
they can get some b-listers into this
yeah
absolutely and uh i hope they also i
know this might have some conflicts and
stuff with contracts and whatnot but i
really hope that they actually tie in
the the daredevil
uh iron fist oh no all that stuff that's
all that's not contract netflix like
agreed to take over that part of the
marvel universe see that is what is
pissing me off marvel is doing it right
they're not letting any characters go
unless it incorporates into the universe
so that we have this giant continuity
project that is going to be freaking
amazing
dc is like
nolan go make batman you know
zack snyder go make superman that's fine
you didn't read a comic we don't care do
what you want with the guy yeah batman
superman kills people that's cool we'll
just go ahead and do that that's
whatever
then then the marvel cinematic universe
is horrible but they do loosely make it
so that it could have tied into
everything i don't know if you've
watched the black widow punisher show
movie
no no no no
it's avengers confidential and it's
black widow and punisher and while it's
not direct continuity if you don't know
what's going on like continuity wise
you could assume it's a part of it it's
fine
it doesn't break anything
yeah it's animated
but it but it links enough into there
that you can understand it and be like
oh okay i watched the avengers i know
who black widow is who's the punisher oh
this is cool oh look more history on the
black widow that is in line with what's
going on with the avengers
so you don't like we know it's not
technically in there but it could
totally be in there dc is just like
what yeah
like the animated universe is all by
itself
that is now following the new 52 the
movies are doing their own complete
nolan thing you know we got the tv show
over at cw cw can do what they want with
the characters and dc and like nobody
sat down and said hey guys we have like
three camps why don't we just merge half
of this you know
yeah yeah well i mean another thing is
they do a great job on their animated
stuff that's what i was gonna animated
stuff is unbelievable
i mean
most hardcore fans will argue with you
on a few things like in justice league
war why is superman a dick um my opinion
a lot of the things people argue about
is to condense it into an hour movie
you know in the comics suggested the
gorge and what war was based on superman
was a dick
but in the comics we had enough time to
elaborate why
while in the movie superman is just a
dick
yeah but okay but so here's the thing
though like like if you sit down and
watch the doctor strange animated film
like there were some differences between
that and the comic but they weren't like
very noticeable like there was there
were small itty bitty differences but
basically dr stephen strange was a
neurosurgeon he was a dick he got in a
car wreck lost the use of his hands
didn't want to be relegated to the
position of a teacher so he spent all
his money trying to find a cure stumble
across the ancient one into bed and then
you know over time becomes the sorcerer
supreme i mean that was that's basically
the story of doctor strange
summed up in 10 seconds i mean that's
and the the animated the animated movie
really follows that exact pattern and
that's that's what i really enjoy about
marvel's animated film that's what i
really enjoy about their their whole
thing because you're right they do have
this this cool continuity going on but
everything's related like you could sit
down and watch all these independent
films and know exactly what's going on
yeah even the stuff that isn't it's like
someone sits down and goes okay we're
not going to incorporate your movie into
our overall movie theme you're going to
do your own thing but you have to make
sure that you hit this note this note
you do this and you you talk about this
hit those four things and you can have
the right you can have the rights to
what you want
all right so so here's my question about
the animated film with uh punisher and
and black widow so
how did they depict a punisher because
almost every single version like when
you had thomas jane playing the punisher
in 2004 whenever it was like every
almost every single version of the
punisher oh and this one he's the guy
runs around guns and kills people does
what he wants shield tries to recruit
him he says that fury does he's doing
things his own way when he they finally
do recruit the punisher he still does
his own way matter of fact they get in
there and he's like all right doing my
own thing [ __ ] you
well so here's the thing here's the
thing about frank castle like frank
castle is the punisher like he he had a
personal code like his code was that if
he's gonna fight somebody he'll fight
them in an honorable way like you won't
just kill them arbitrarily but you know
he'll fight them and you know
like in hand-to-hand combat or but
whatever it is like he'll make his
presence known and let them know like
i'm the punisher and i'm i'm probably
gonna kill you you know and then they
would get into a fight and then he would
end up killing it yeah no it pretty much
does that if i remember correctly i saw
a couple weeks ago now but okay but
because that was one of the things that
drove me insane is they would always
depict him as like a mass murderer just
arbitrary killer with no real it opens
up with him like
killing a bunch of gangsters and stuff
then he goes to the head of the gangster
and he gives like a whole speech about
the guy and then shield shows up and
that's when the movie kicks off this
show's like you you ruined our sting and
he's like i don't do things your way you
would have let him stay in the streets
for three more weeks but i killed him
it's good
so and then the whole thing i'm trying
to chase that one guy down but uh
um
but i mean
and that's and that's that's what i
understand that's what i don't
understand about this this justice
league casting like the casting options
just seems like they're doing it just to
get us to do this talk about the movie
yeah no one says down and goes okay ben
affleck would make a good batman they
all sit down and go if we cast ben
affleck will you believe what the fans
are gonna say
it'll be everywhere
okay okay get a supermodel to be wonder
woman it's gonna be freaking hilarious
well that's that's the difference
because at the end of the day like when
however long this marvel thing goes on
for i mean they've got it going on
forever and ever and ever and ever but
in the year 2050 assuming people are
still buying blu-rays or something like
that when somebody is sitting at best
buy and they've got this great big huge
you know 20
blu-ray set from marvel and they've got
a great big huge 20 blu-ray set from dc
which one are they more likely to choose
when the marvel one is interrelated and
you can watch each one independently or
you can watch them all in order what i
liked about the marvel casting was they
picked people who actually looked like
the characters and could play the
character properly they didn't pick the
big stars they picked the medium road
guys and these this launched a lot of
their careers robert downey jr's career
got restarted by iron man you know yeah
uh krill chris helmsley like i dude he
was just nothing but romantic comedies
before he was you know thor
uh yeah what's the guy that plays
why am i forgetting i was yeah i was
trying to remember his name it's chris
something or other yeah it's like
another chris but like and he was
another romantic comedy guy he didn't
have much of a career then he became
captain america now it's everywhere i
mean they didn't go into the bottom of
the barrel and pick their superheroes
out everybody kind of had some kind of
but they they made sure that the
actresses and actors matched when yeah
when it comes to dc it's like you picked
henry cavill
i can give you ben affleck to and extend
but none of your other casting choices
seem to make any sense
but jesse eisenberg
i mean that's their casting choices are
so off the wall crazy that when a april
fools gag rumor run around that justin
bieber was going to play robin everyone
believed it i believed it man
i saw a picture of him holding a skit
of him playing robin and i was like oh
my god there's no way this is true it's
because it's because their decisions are
so insane everyone was like oh
they would totally do that what the hell
dc they would do that man pull in those
12 year old girls i mean they would they
would do that and pull on those kids i
really hope it's a good movie but i
don't really have much faith in dc in
terms of continuity in order for them
to pull off a a continuous universe
right well
they don't have the setup
they don't they marvel spent the iron
man and iron man 2 setting everything up
they they took the time they weren't
like oh how many movies can we get out
before this fad dies you know they were
like oh yeah if the fad dies whatever we
still have the avengers we've still made
something out of this you know and and
this leads me to this actually is a
great segue to days of future past
because what you just said you don't
have the faith and i'm doing this now
this is
i've gotten a lot of heated discussions
about days of future past and i think
even you and i have gotten into a few
discussions about a rob i've gotten a
bunch of the comic book store
everyone who's a comic book fan hates
days of future past everyone who is not
a comic book fan loves days of future
past
i have yet to see anybody say it's a
shitty movie and they weren't a comic
book fan
and this kind of leads to the way i'm
trying to go into justice league
you can't go with days of future past
we'll go into about more about it in a
minute because this is more your domain
but in my opinion when it comes to these
comic book movies because even avengers
and everything messed it up to an extent
you have to assume they're a separate
universe everyone blips the freak out
because they sent wolverine back they
did it because wolverine's popular why
do you think the non-comic book fans
liked the movie
yeah if they had sent back kitty pride
everyone would have been like oh where's
hugh jackman and his sexy abs
just a minute a minute you know what you
know he's good yeah oh dude i was
sitting in that theater and i was like
oh my god that guy's ready
yeah i am 100 straight i'm married but
i'm gonna say when he got up out of bed
but naked i'm like oh my god what is his
workout i need to do that yeah i was
like man i need to get back in the gym
like i said i'm saying i was like man
he's just like oh yeah what up guys
you're gonna leave that in the rock
all over
that man i gotta get jacked at some
point because if i don't yeah yeah
hugh jackman you just you just made
every comic book fan cry because i think
all of us like to sit down and read and
uh we're not too worried about the gym
exactly exactly um but it's like
and that's what people don't seem to get
like everyone flipped out about man of
steel i mean and that that's why i think
this is a great segue
everyone you guys aren't huge dc fans i
don't know but i don't know how much of
a fan you are david but the the dc fans
flipped out because superman killed zod
superman doesn't kill
superman but that's incorrect
as far as comic books go superman
doesn't kill until three years ago
you reboot in the new 52 and he has
killed a krypton a kryptonian dragon he
has killed um doomsday now um i believe
he's killed so he killed hell uh which
was another kryptonian guy
he's selective and he does it when it's
needed that's what that's what the new
superman made because like in a lot of
the animated stuff i've watched for
superman and some of the comic books
like in all star superman for example
and i know that's not in the whole you
know dc
main universe but
he kills that alien at the end right and
that throws that alien right into the
sun doesn't he yeah i believe it's been
a while since i read all-star but but i
mean there are instances where superman
has killed
exactly for a good reason it's always
been a good reason it's always been
because he had to exactly what happened
to man of steel he had to kill zod or
zod was going to i beam all those guys
but the thing is
he's always killed in the alternate
universes so you need to assume that man
of steel is not your
72 72-year on running you know action
comics superman he's somewhere closer to
the new 52 superman he's somewhere
closer to the new reboots he's a
different universe that we have a
multiverse for a reason guys you know
yeah
and that applies to days of future past
also everyone's freaking out because of
kitty pride
yeah
and people freak out because stuff isn't
exactly like the comics and stuff isn't
exactly like the comics because if even
a comic book fan went into the movie
theater and watched days of future past
exactly like it was they'd complain
exactly as much because there's no
surprise yeah exactly exactly it would
have been ruined you know 20 years ago
when days of future past came out well
that's actually what i was talking about
about the other day i think we first met
we were asking our opinions about it and
i told them i'm like i read a really
good thing from a radio show and the guy
was saying there's a reason why these
stories don't 100 make their comic books
because regardless of comic books fans
going oh my god they made man of steel
and daisy feature pass for me i'm a
comic book fan no they did comic books
sell like on a good good sale like 60
000 issues
those movies do 100 millions 250 million
that is not the comic book audience
yeah it's not it's not regardless of us
loving our movies and loving our seeing
our superheroes up in the screen and
animated stuff i am actually enjoying it
more ever since i stopped trying to
relate them to the comics
i was going to say that i dude i agree
with you so much because i used to be
like a real big stickler for that like i
went and saw the original like the first
x-men film i was like this movie sucks
saber tooth don't know each other and
magneto wants to turn the world's
leaders into mutants and i was like this
is this is absolutely stupid once i
walked away from that and i was like
just go see it for the sake of it being
a marvel film like i was like this is
awesome
these movies are amazing i did the exact
same thing with x-men i want to go see
with my wife and she's not a huge x-men
fan she likes more of the dc stuff in
general just why we're more of a dc
house but uh um
we got out of the x-men and i'm she's
like well why are you upset i was
explaining everything they messed up in
continuity and x-men one two and three i
hated them for that reason but i watched
every single one of them i hated
spider-man 3 for the same reason
spider-man 3 sam raimi just said how bad
can i make this
yeah basically i'm being rushed out the
door how bad can i destroy this
i don't want to do a four and we're
gonna make sure i don't do a four
um but it was like you know i hated them
for the same reason but when mar when
when marvel came out with iron man i
didn't know anything about iron man iron
man was like a d-lister yeah he was an
avenger but he was some guy in a suit of
armor no one cared his biggest his
biggest thing in comic history was that
he was an alcoholic
that was it i mean he was yeah like like
robert downey jr made iron man popular
he was cool and he had absolutely rolls
here and there but he was he's not
nearly as interesting in the comics as
he is in the films so when i went to go
see iron man i had no idea about iron
man so i had no idea if the continuity
was accurate or not and i loved the
movie and when i came out of that movie
i looked up iron man and i saw what they
did mess up and i'm like but you know
what i liked that movie because i didn't
try to compare this beforehand it's fun
to look at it afterwards and go oh they
messed that up oh you know now i feel
like a super nerd because i know what
really happened with extremists you know
i know who the mandarin really is he's
not some guy trying to pretend yeah well
did you see the marvel one shout out
where they remedied that
yeah yeah well he's becoming mandarin
now because there's so much backlash
well he's either becoming the mandarin
or the real manner that's going to
confront him
yeah something yeah i didn't see that i
saw the trailer for it i didn't actually
watch the full thing from what i had
heard it was setting up for the mandarin
to really show up finally yeah basically
yeah
but
and this is where people get it wrong
like i went to the comic books for the
day after days of future past came in
and i walked in there the first thing
they're like did you watch jason future
pass i'm like yeah i kind of liked it he
goes oh it was so bad it was horrendous
it was
it was so just messed up like kitty pry
needed to go in the past and you know
the sentinels they looked horrendous
what is this mystique stuff and oh my
god but if you don't try to compare it
to the 1981 storyline
that no one has read pretty much at this
point in comic you know everyone talks
about asia future past but go to your
average comic book reader do you really
think he's read it you know that's
that's the thing that's the thing like
it's like days of future past is one of
the most well-known chris claremont
x-men stories and it's well-known and
name only for the most part exactly well
not nate they know
it's well known because of the future
x-men
no one knows the true story they just
know that there's a future of x-men
where the apocalypse happened well
that's why i said we were discussing
this before i was like i guarantee that
like 99 of people who are not comic book
fans and are going to see this movie
want to see what it's like in the future
like they want to see like they want to
see x-men get killed and here's the
thing here was the thing like i know a
lot of people complained a lot of people
said oh my god you know this and this
and that and that but at the end of the
day that was a good movie i don't care
what people say like i am an avid x-men
fan i am an avid marvel comics x-men fan
so if you know for the most part like i
would argue until the bitter end when it
came to different things and continuity
changes so on and so forth but as an
avid x-men fan i went into the days of
future past and i was initially
skeptical because it's a fox x-men film
and they have a bad track record in
terms of making x-men films first class
wasn't bad though
for okay first class first class was
good yeah but from the time i got into
that movie the time that i left i was
not bored i was entertained 100 percent
of the time did i feel like hugh jackman
overtook the role no and that was the
great thing because hugh jackman was the
one that went into the past but hugh
jackman didn't really do anything the
entire time he did and i actually loved
that i loved the fact that they used
hugh jackman to pull everybody in
wolverine wolverine wolverine and they
spent the first 30 minutes about
wolverine and then they just went to
everybody else
here's wolverine check out his claws you
love wolverine he's gonna make a few
more jokes but he's gonna follow
professor x in magneto and mystique and
we're gonna follow that plot and we're
gonna follow quicksilver and we're not
really wolverine's not gonna save the
day now my only real complaint about it
was in the very ending he should have
done something because he was like i
told you he was useless
at the very end he just gets chucked and
he's like all right well he didn't even
touch anything
let's see i thought that was i've been
thinking about that since since you said
that i thought that was a smart move
because it was a way to get wolverine
out of the picture because the problem
is that when when people go and see an
x-men film and hugh jackman is on the
front cover like plastered all over the
front cover is like you know the main
star so to speak then the question
becomes what is he going to do like is
wolverine really going to be the one to
save the day but we saw the movie
progress in a way where ultimately it
was basically charles xavier magneto and
mystique's fight it didn't have anything
to do with wolverine wolverine was
simply there to monitor and to make sure
that things went according to plan right
but i liked the element of cr of
mystique's character of jennifer
lawrence my homegirl
you know
getting you know her character
developing to the point where she was
able to like basically like you know
establish herself as an independent
character and so at the end of the movie
it basically came down to her struggle
which which side is she's going to align
with she's going to align with charles
xavier and his peaceful coexistence or
is she going to align with magneto and
we have to strike first right so i i
like the fact that they they spent
basically the entire movie developing
her character either directly with her
or for the most part indirectly through
the experiences that she had that we
didn't see with magneto and the
experiences from the first film with
xavier and so by the end of the movie
we're left with this question which side
is mystique going to choose and i
thought it was done extremely well and i
thought it was done in an amazing way
and the fact that wolverine was
basically totally removed from the film
by being wrapped in metal and thrown to
the bottom of the potomac river was a
great way to allow her to step into that
role i agree with you 100 and actually
it literally just dawned on me right now
when you said that um but this also
showed the average moviegoer who's not a
comic book fan that wolverine is not
this unstoppable beast that can solve
everything exactly because that exactly
in the comic books we know that we like
you know avengers versus x-men when
wolverine went on his own solo mission
he really couldn't do much other than
find hope and say that he's going to
kill her you know asian he had to go
back in time and then get thrown around
and tore apart he's not but the movies
made him out to be like wolverine will
solve everything wolverine has
unstoppable he can heal through anything
he's just
you can't stop wolverine
and this movie removed that from the
equation they were like nope he's still
a guy with claws bye
yeah pretty much i mean pretty much i
mean that's like like in the civil war
storyline i'm getting ready to do like
there's there's there's two comics where
wolverine just hunts nitro like that's
all he does nitro was the one that blew
up that part of stamford connecticut and
there's comics wolverine is hunting but
that's it like that's all wolverine
really does like he's just basically
hunting for nitro and then nitro blows
up wolverine survives and then he
confronts him he's like i'm not dead yet
and that's really it like there's really
you know no great big huge you know
wolverine saves the world kind of thing
going on wolverine single-handedly ends
the civil war wolverine is a guy that
can heal from stuff and he's got claws
and he can kill people right you know in
the grand scheme of everything that goes
on in marvel comics wolverine's just not
that important he's not that powerful
and he's not that special he's just a
cool guy he's that anti he's just a
really cool guy yeah the anti-hero that
survived the 90s yeah basically yeah i'm
gonna wear jeans and drink beer yeah i
mean basically
basically but fun side note is anyone
everyone here aware that wolverine
cannot get drunk
yeah yeah well just like captain america
captain america can't get drunk either i
thought he could get drunk it took a
night well at least not in the movies
but he has like a healing factor to some
extent too and he has an increased
metabolism well it's it's metabolism
that's the thing like like captain
america to my knowledge doesn't really
have a healing factor no okay not not
not comparable to like wolverine for the
record
i mean it was supposed to be more of a
joking sense but at the beginning of
original sin they're all eating a ton of
steak and captain america does have a
fast metabolism but he even comments i
need to stop eating i have to run like
10 miles tomorrow to bring this thing
off
yeah
that was that was a really really cool
scene when you had wolverine and captain
america nick fury and
who was the fourth black widow yeah all
eating a steak yeah that was pretty cool
and what rings like well hey bub you're
going to run anyway why don't you go
ahead and eat it and he's like no no i
think i'm done with well if you're not
going to eat it punk
exactly okay okay so so let's take a
second to talk about original sin number
three all right so have you guys read
original sin number three yet
oh are we done with days of the future
past we're just we're done we're wrapped
up well if you've got someone to talk
about it you gotta come up with a segway
we gotta be like i mean i'm i'm fine by
the way about this days of future past
we have wolverine but did you know what
else wolverine is in original sin what
happened
okay actually i can at least be in some
shitty segway
all right so since you've brought back
up since you brought danger future pass
back up um all right let's talk about
the sentinels for a second i want to
talk about the sentence because benny
and i vinnie and i we've had this i
don't think them
the sentinels the sentinels are like
five stories tall
unstoppable giant robots they're not
metamorphosing they're not changing
their appearance they're not made out of
scales
i like like these are these sentinels
weren't bad but they weren't sentinels
that's my opinion
okay if we were gonna have something
else we needed i was looking for
something enormous giant like the size
of a building
something that is a that is an actual
problem not something that's almost man
size with some guns that's pretty much
what these sentinels were they weren't
even they should have just called them
like a baby sentinel or sentinels 1.0 or
but see this is the thing is
i i'm a big watcher of the animated
series or at least i was growing up
everyone
starting to read comics
and are sentinels in the comics and in
the animated series really that
dangerous yeah because
like
i i remember watching the animated
series and wolverine would literally cut
them in half like they were paper well
here's the problem one sentinel has
never been a problem for the x-men yeah
but the problem is when one sentinel
finds you there's normally like 10
others coming up and when they're that
large that's the problem and that that
is they're so big yeah the whole x-men
team can take out one wolverine can
cleave the top of it up beast can jump
up knock the head off everyone can you
know but it takes the whole team
typically to take one down and then you
get 10 of them because one alerted the
whole group
now here here's the thing about
sentinels and i was actually thinking
about this before because you said that
you didn't like sentinels because of the
fact that they could they could you know
um they were shape-shifters and stuff
like that all right so
we see a point when they finally invade
the chinese you know wherever chinese
temple wherever it is that they're at
all right there's there's like like
hundreds of them there you know
thousands of people oh yeah like the
major style of ships to drop the ball
like what is that
all right now here here was a thing
here's one one thing that i found
interesting in the beginning of the film
there were what maybe three or four of
them that single-handedly made basically
managed to destroy almost everybody or
at least at the time it was perceived
they destroyed everybody until we
learned that no they didn't
somehow well bishop it somehow have
somehow gone back in time and warned
them
that that was that's a plot hole that
i'm not even gonna try to get into your
life wait wait wait wait wait wait i
don't i don't even know there's a plot
holder he goes back to time he warns
them they don't go to that spot all
right all right
pride
is with the group and she has been
sending his consciousness yeah they're
pretty much
establishing what the power is that's
what they did i i understand that but
okay i'm gonna be i'm gonna be a little
nitpicky here
bishop does not have bishop is a time
traveler but he's a technological time
traveler uses technology to travel
through time all right kitty pride
never had the ability to send somebody's
consciousness anywhere because they're
not going to introduce michael we're not
guessing i know i know i wish they had i
really wish even if it was just like a
tip of the hat and franklin richards
dies in the first five seconds of the
film you know i would like to have seen
either one of them but nonetheless i'm
not you know that's why i said i don't
want to but nonetheless so rob rob we
just said you have to look at it as a
different continuity you have to look at
it as a different
this continuity kitty's pride's phasing
ability has somehow given her a second
mutation at time travel
i mean it happens man it happened i mean
emma frost's diamond form was a
secondary mutation so
um
what i thought was interesting about the
signals is basically we saw for them for
all intents and purposes everybody
killed by no less there are no more than
three sentinels right and then at the
end of the movie they have this huge
horde of them that show up if the
sentinels can shapeshift and they can
adapt to any kind of any kind of attack
they're basically all nimrod then why
would we have this huge army of signals
this is why i kind of agreed with benny
when it came to the sentinels the thing
about the sentinels dave is that there's
there's there's thousands of them like
there's so many of them because by the
time we get to like x factor and by the
time we get to the return to x-men so we
have the red or i'm sorry the gold and
the blue x-men teams the sentinels are
being mass produced like they're they're
they're an assembly line product they're
no longer being created by hand
matter of fact the true days of future
past line and i think they slightly they
i got really confused in the movie how
they explain this but the way it happens
is they've become so many sentinels that
they start mass producing themselves so
that's how we lose control of them yeah
yeah they start yeah they they become
autonomous and start diving like they
they kind of become like skynet of the
marvel universe
but um but there's there's just so many
of them so while they're not you know
astronomically powerful i mean in days
of future past comic wolverine was
totally incinerated by one but that was
like a super powerful sentinel that was
designed to guard the home base
but yeah but nonetheless you know i mean
like the in marvel comics i don't know
if you're familiar with them but they
had a character named nimrod he was a
super sentinel from the days of future
past that was actually a point that
extended beyond what we saw in the
comics but he was like the ultimate
sentinel
and so he was able he could basically do
anything he could shape-shift he could
adapt to any attack he was like the
sentinels that we saw in the film and
that was the first thing that i thought
when i saw them i was like these guys
remind me of nimrod like they all look
they all seem like nimrod they don't
really look like him because nimrod was
white and he you know merged with bash
and all that kind of stuff nonetheless
like
they remind me of nimrod you know they
can sense weaknesses in people they can
do all kinds of different things and so
the way they were portrayed really kind
of seemed to run counter to the the
basis of the sentinels and the in the
fact that it's just the sheer number of
them that overwhelm whatever it is that
they're fighting as opposed to them
being adapt being able to adapt to
anything because if you had sentinels
they could adapt to anything then you
would really only need like a hundred of
them at any particular time you would
run into the borg problem
exactly yeah exactly he would they were
just
borg will throw five people at you you
take them all out now you can't do that
again and then yeah
and you're like ah
yeah god i love it
yeah but but that was the thing that was
the one thing that that really kind of
irked me now in terms of like the
sentinels themselves the signals to me
were a backdrop i mean they were just
really showing us how bad the future is
how bleak it is and how this is just the
one hope that they have
but here was the one thing that that
of all the things i didn't really care
for
the one thing that really kind of
bothered me and there were a lot of
things that i liked
was that charles xavier was alive and
that was something that i just didn't
really like because
charles xavier dying was really like a
pivotal point in the comics
do you know how they explained that in
the movie
about charles xavier living yeah
i don't know i don't remember that i
don't remember that either but i i don't
even know where
your next man i can't find where it's
revealed but what they're basically
stating is he died in x3
the man in the bed was apparently his
identical twin brother
oh come on
no way this has supposedly been revealed
by brian uh snyder what's his name is
brian
and i'm not 100 aware but if you look at
the timelines it's in everybody's
timeline
so it's a nose away you're kidding nope
it's in everybody's timeline and it's
revealed in some like interview or
something i don't know but supposedly
that body was his identical twin brother
who's been brain dead since birth
brain dead since birth so xavier takes
it over and they explain the the the
legs thing because it's linked to his
powers
by this movie they they could explain
that when he has his powers he gets
crippled again
that's how they explain why when he
takes over his identical twins brother's
body he's also crippled
oh my god i i thought i thought they
just said
i i'm sorry guys but x-men three never
happens it's
like i thought that's how well no with
the timeline correction it never
happened yeah but with the daisy future
past original timeline they're saying it
still happened and everything went
through
let's see i'm not upset about that if
days of future pass gets rid of x-men
three then brian singer is my new best
friend because trash
70s 80s they kind of got rid of all of
them now
yeah the only ones that are important
are first class and days of future past
so exactly that's what i was going to
say because now they can pretty much do
anything they want to they can just
reboot it entirely supposedly he's
already planning his phoenix story that
he was originally going to do that they
completely got rid of in three so here's
my question
so here's my question
like if you guys remember in x3 probably
the only real redeeming factor in the
movie was ben foster playing warren
worthington the third and i really want
to see ben foster come back because if
ben foster comes back as angel and we
have x-men apocalypse coming up that
means we get to see archangel now
whether or not he loses his wings
because a business partner blew up his
jet or not i don't know
but i i would really love to see
archangel in a future expert
i i don't want to go too much into this
because we don't know anything about it
and this could probably turn into a
whole entire show of speculation but i
don't think they're going to do age of
apocalypse
i don't think we can go from one
end of the world plot line to another
end of the world plot yeah i think it's
gonna show up
yeah okay okay well even if they don't
do age of apocalypse then the
introduction of apocalypse basically
means it means a couple things i mean it
could be a number of storylines that
lead to age of apocalypse down the road
but you gotta remember when it came to
apocalypse apocalypse was largely an x
factor character so we're talking about
x factor x-men so the question is are
the original x-men just gonna take off
from xavier and do their own thing right
he's just going to be like an x-men
villain and you know he's not going to
be it's not going to be x-factor or
anything i mean i'm i'm curious what
direction they take this i mean the
original plan was x-men origins they
were going to do all the characters
instead they did first class because
wolverine just did so horribly and it
was terrible and then well yeah but then
we had the origin and then we had first
class and i'm waiting for spin-offs i
mean spider-man's already announced
spider-man amazing spider-man 3 is 2018.
between then we've got apparently venom
sinister six and like two other freaking
movies about villains like what
all right so the sinister six i think is
going to be interesting because in the
amazing spider-man 2 we actually saw
elements of the sinister six like
spider-man lost his powers in the
sinister six storyline in the beginning
because he was just like it was like a
mental block he was depressed about
uncle ben dying so you know would it be
it being his fault or whatever the
reason was but nonetheless like we saw
like that really kind of picking up in
the sinister six and the comics in the
beginning but in the movie like gwen
stacy dies and so he really just kind of
loses a reason to be spider-man anymore
venom makes sense we can make venom a
hero you can make him an anti-hero and
you can in the end he can just go true
evil whatever because venom's done that
sinister six has never been good guys
who is the protagonist
andrew garfield shows up for 15 minutes
of it just to be there and kick their
ass when we see behind the scenes [ __ ]
happening
well but that was the thing like the
original sinister six story was really
cool because it was basically like it
was like the movie uh game of death from
bruce lee like he just went up levels
every time he went up a level it was a
new guy that's basically how the
sinister six works like you had um
doctor octopus who was like i've been
defeated by spider-man countless times
so i'm going to a similar team each time
he fights a member of the sinister six
he's gonna fight them in a location
that's conducive to their powers right
so he fights electro in an electrical
plant you know stuff like that so the
question is like is that how the
sinister six film is going to go is it
going to be a series of spider-man
fighting different villains or is it
going to be i'm fighting all six people
at one time and who are the six people
going to be i mean paul giamatti showed
up at the very end as rhino so obviously
we're going to see rhino continue on in
other
films wasn't right that was mecca right
now
yeah there were people people were
pissed off about that like there were a
lot of actors
i mean rhino was a physical guy he was
dressed up like a rhino
i think they're probably gonna go there
i mean without going into speculation on
this we can do a whole show on amazing
spider-man why we hate it and why we
love it but what does anyone love it no
i don't i don't really i don't really
like it that much but uh
as far as like
these oh i totally lost my train of
thought i just totally i just started to
think about rhino and just
i just kind of like fixated on rhino i'm
like yeah but
uh the ultimate spider-man tv show the
sinister six are introduced and it's in
a way of doctor octopus shows us have
you seen the cartoon
all right um i've seen bits and pieces
is it miles morales is playing the
ultimate spider-man no no it's peter
parker before all that happened oh okay
but dr octopus shows up and in the
background of a lot of the episodes he's
putting together the sinister six
until they finally get introduced and
the spider-man has to go fight them all
and go crazy and blah blah blah blah but
then he has to get help to finish him
yeah in an ultimate universe he gets his
he gets iron fist and white cat and all
these other people but um
that that's
that's where i don't see why we can have
a sinister six solo movie like
we couldn't even give spider-man enough
time and amazing spider-man 2. we're
gonna have a whole movie devoted down to
the sinister six forming like
well see i would
i hope they do it smart because the one
lesson that i think that sony should
have learned from spider-man 3 is you
can't have too many villains introduced
in such a short amount of time and have
a good plot i mean we had sandman we had
harry osborn and we had venom all
introduced or not really introduced but
all either introduced or reintroduced as
bad guys to spider-man over the course
of a two and a half hour movie and it
was a total piece of trash the movie was
absolutely awful because it was
everywhere there was no real like a
linear line it was everywhere it was
trying to set up all of these future
movies and you're like uh
where are we going villains we had two
major villains and one like half villain
yeah i i felt like it could have been
two two and a half movies like
like i felt like it could have been
split up a lot more
it really could have but i think that
see here's here's what i think is
happening in all honesty when it comes
to sony and fox i think they're looking
at the marvel cinematic universe and
they're looking at movies like captain
america the winter soldier that are
approaching a billion dollars in revenue
you know they're looking at these movies
that are just super popular they're
looking at all the fan talk about the
age of ultron or the ultron uh in
avengers 2 they're looking at you know
fans talking about captain america three
which was an incredibly stupid mistake
for dc or for uh fox to say they're
going to release justice league on the
same day as captain america three that
was an incredibly bad dc i don't think
gives a crap about their movie i don't
think they
don't care
dc is like how much buzz can we make
about how bad this movie is so everybody
goes to see it well okay you can't you
can't look okay dc cannot look at
captain america one and then captain
america two on top of the avengers and
all the marvel cinematic universe movies
to date and say our movie is going to be
able to successfully compete with
captain america three in what universe
would anyone believe that they're going
to be able to make a movie that's going
to rival captain america 3. i love it
i do and i hate the stupid stuff they do
i hate the delays i hate what they've
done with a lot of these characters
which we're going to talk about at the
end of this what they've done to
supergirl lately but
i i love them to death and i'm going to
see captain america before the justice
league movie
i know it'll be good i know nothing
about it and i know it'll be good but
the man of steel movie just sounds worse
and worse and worse
it does it does i mean every time i read
about it you know every time somebody
mentions something like you were telling
i'm like oh my god i mean this is i
don't want to go see that but i think
that that fox and sony are looking at
the marvel cinematic universe and
they're going into panic mode they're
like we've got to be able to create
movies that are competitive
me too
yeah well yeah every because right now
sony and fox are dealing with everyone's
like no just give it to marvel just give
it back to marvel just give it back to
marvel just give it back and then
they're like oh no it's ours ours is
ours we can make a good movie i swear
and here's what i think
i think they could still like they have
to be able to make some arrangement
where
they can still make money off of x-men
centric movies
and spider-man centric movies but still
give the property back to marvel to to
use in the avengers movies
and maybe make a percentage like maybe
make it say hey
spiderman
is both companies want all that hundred
million
you know that's basically it yeah
and then it also becomes a problem of
this though you know okay look at it
this way we have an avengers movie you
crammed spider-man into that
spider-man's gonna get minimal time he's
not gonna get very much just like every
other avenger the major movie's great
right but nobody got like core spotlight
on that movie how much are they gonna
pay spider-man to use this i mean i mean
sony to use spider-man hey we want to
use him for three scenes okay that'll be
50 million what you know
spider-man's a flagship character for
marvel like he's a he's a major marvel
character yeah he's not they're trying
to make a new one i don't know if you've
noticed that
what now since sony won't give it back
to them nova is popping up everywhere
with spider-man
they're trying to make kidnova the new
i'm a angsty teen character oh okay oh
yeah no no no
they're pushing nova to make him as
popular as spider-man to get him into
everything because since sony won't give
it back they're like well screw it we'll
just make another big character
okay okay i thought you were saying like
in the films they're trying to get nova
into the movies i was like when did this
become announced like i've never heard
this
i guarantee this is this is my
speculation but i guarantee you after
avengers 2 we're going to start to see
novacore i'd be well i mean after
guardians of the game the guardians of
the galaxy does well because nova is
being integrated into so much comic book
in uh uh tv show lore
they're going to start guardians
galaxies as well we're probably going to
see a nova helmet that's my speculation
we're going to see a nova helmet in the
movie and guardians of the galaxy 2 will
be intertied with a nova central movie
nova centric movie which will then wrap
around into avengers 3's what i'm
thinking
here's a question this is happening
since they've set up the whole uh
infinity gauntlet type hints
showing up
i can see
uh x-men going in the direction of age
of apocalypse i can see the marvel
cinematic universe going toward
uh you know thanos and the infinity
gauntlet towards the end of phase three
and i also see
uh the sinister six coming up at around
the same time in spider-man if they do
that setup right yeah they're all trying
to set it all up for that but they're
starting with what i was doing
this is what they're doing marvel can't
have x-men marvel can't have spider-man
so okay we have the avengers but they
have they have a massive universe of
characters
who else can we use that no one owns
their rights to guardians of the galaxy
why do you think guardians of the galaxy
they're pushing it so hardcore they
picked an obscure character and they're
gonna try to basically put them on the
level of like x-men and stuff like that
to basically be like look fox we don't
need it so screw you
well here i mean here's the thing too
like and i was i was reading about this
the other day because
i'm gonna bring i'm gonna bring back
adam warlock i'm gonna bring adam
warlock back into the discussion
real quick look at this way look at this
way okay they can't have wolverine right
yeah we still have drakken we still have
x-23
do not do not even try and tell me that
if we did guardians of the galaxy and
then we introduced miracles and avengers
2. they could not bring in x 23 and it
would be like they basically make her a
real character finally and it would just
wolverine with boobs guys what do you
think you know
let me tell you something if if x23 pops
up in the marvel cinematic universe
people are going to look at that and say
it's just their attempt to try to get
wolverine i'm not going to complain no
x23 was cool but i'm just saying
are miracles
you know you could easily have x23 leave
her past vague she's not really she's
not i mean it's probably like a legal
battle right now but she's not really an
x-men she's not really an avenger she's
always been kind of a separate entity
that gets shoehorned because she's such
an underdeveloped character she gets
shoehorned into everything she's had her
own comics she's been on every team she
just got shoehorned all over the place
you know and you could if you developed
her we would have over even boobs
nope we lost rob oh completely oh we did
the complete job he dropped so how are
you david
pretty good
okay my skype just crashed i don't know
we're good we're having our own
conversation here what do you think
about moving the boobs david
oh wolverine boobs would be cool
i don't really know much about x23 yet
but
she's basically clone of wolverine and
it literally was marvel's attempt to go
hey wolverine's so popular why don't we
give him boobs and so they made a clone
that's really that's really what the
whole core of the whole thing was but my
argument is if we can't get spider-man
push nova they're trying to get nobody
in the ultimate universe they're trying
to get nova into the core universe
that's why he's all over original sin
they're trying to push him like crazy
they're pushing guardians of the galaxy
instead of the x-men and if you guys
want wolverine give us x-23 or if you
want to go all broody guy type give us
dragon you can tell that marvel's trying
to go
like
either inter-dimensional or out into
space with their film franchise well
yeah i mean think about guardians of the
galaxy i mean i hate to say it rob
because you love the x-men but on a
movie level
tell me right now who you think is going
to do a better movie
guardians of the galaxy
or
the x-men apocalypse movie
all right it
it depends on how they do it man i mean
it really depends if guardians of the
galaxy is going to be like a silly and
comedic film
with
some interjections
silly and comedic characters we still
see that's that's
exactly that's what i'm talking about
like
quicksilver
yeah it does but i mean but look at like
look at peter quill all right star-lord
was never like for the most part a super
serious character he would crack jokes
all the time you know but when it like
he had a workout when it came down to it
like he knew what needed to be done but
like rocket raccoon was like the serious
you know died in the wool you know go
balls to the wall kind of thing there's
actually a really cool point in the uh
in the uh thanos imperative where
once they once they find thanos and he's
just like freaking out he's mindless and
kind of going crazy um
uh
rocket raccoon tells him that if he if
he keeps doing what he's doing they're
gonna drop him into a gravity well well
he'll just be he'll have to live for all
eternity like you just won't be able to
die and he's like that'll be your
punishment eternal life and so like for
him it's torture but it's but there's
some really really cool points in the
comics when rocket raccoon is like a
super serious guy and and knows how to
get stuff done so it depends on how they
write it if it's a silly movie and it's
just kind of funny and you know when
it's like the jar jar binks of uh of the
marvel cinematic universe yeah it'll be
people will hate it and it'll be
absolutely true people think we're gonna
get that with ant-man because of the new
director they just let go but that's
another oh my
um
rocket raccoon in the trailer at least
in every shot in the trailer that he's
in
he looks serious yeah
like he's not getting the latest comic
book he's been captured and they're
going to dissect him and he's freaking
out that's the top is the latest great
guardians of the galaxy
i mean rocket raccoon i describe him to
benny this way rocket raccoon is like
joe petchey from goodfellas like he's
he's
he's hardcore yeah i mean yeah
they picked one of the most cuddly
looking characters and made him the most
hardcore of the group him and
are the hardest core out of the two of
them oh gamora oh my god man i i am so
glad we're seeing gamora and guardians
of the galaxy the unit the universe's
best assassin i am so happy to see her
popping up because she is she's such a
great dynamic character like during the
uh
the what was it the annihilation
storyline i think when the phalanx and
the cree were at war with each other
like she was part of the phalanx and she
was hunting down richard ryder like you
know and eventually like made richard
ryder part of the failings like she was
a great character like she's got some
great stories and even now an original
sin like i don't know if you're at that
point yet i don't know if you've seen
that yet but she's part of the original
sin storyline now
we're supposed to end this discussion
and go to that we we are okay okay okay
so wait wait wait wait wait
i'm going to teach you rob the ways
you guys segway you have to segue so
that's a great segue so you got to be
like you know i don't know if you've
read originals in three for more is
great and original oh oh you haven't
well let's talk about original synthetic
let's let's talk about original
synthetic
segway you don't just cut it you just
keep going
all right so there are some big reveals
in original sim three i mean it's
there's there's like three or four of
them all right the first one what we see
is like bucky barnes and uh gamora and
uh moon knight are basically on this
like interstellar travel trying to
figure out what the heck is going on
they eventually come across like a trail
of bullets in space and when they track
the trail of bullets they land on some
kind of a planet or something like that
they're trying to figure out what the
heck is going on and they realize that
the planet is like another sentient
version of um
of uh
ego the living planet and it's been
killed by somebody like they killed the
planet
so
yeah so they're trying to figure out
what the heck is going on you know what
what in the world is going on here
um
from what i can tell in this storyline
and you may have already revealed this
to me already and told me about it but
from what i can tell in this um the
entire basis of the original sin event
is that the eyes of the watcher give you
information they basically remove
anything that you didn't know about your
life yes
so everything that's ever happened to
you ever happened to
anything that led up to you being where
you are you know about it and what's
really kind of interesting here is that
the eye is like a the orb uses the
powers on like the incredible hulk and
so the incredible for some reason has
this desire to kill tony stark that may
or may not have been revealed to us yet
it may have been that the incredible
hulk was forced to forget the events of
a world war hulk so he's really pissed
off at him because the illuminati shot
him into space i mean they they haven't
revealed that kind of stuff to us yet
but uh
because i've read all the times i just
haven't read the the issue i haven't
read mighty avengers issue number 10 yet
okay
though
you talking about you to read that i
said it's got like a really screw you
ending and you're like ah
okay avengers issue number 29. i think i
read that but i don't i don't remember
how that was that was the more captain
we find out that captain america gets
his memories back at illuminati oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah there's another one i
believe is money avengers number nine or
ten i have it somewhere i just uh mighty
avengers number ten yeah and it's about
doctor straight not doctor strange it's
um
i don't even know his name he's some
random guy that i don't yeah he's uh
he's blue something or rather i can't
remember his name right well in that one
it's revealed that uh because everyone's
trying to solve the mystery of the
watcher we're gonna get the watcher back
the watcher had a son
yeah yeah okay yeah i saw that that's
right yeah it was his wife or something
like that and and which more humanizes
our you know cosmic entity okay great
she made what's his name the uh
godfather for uh
yeah oh wow so
i just saw what oh god
so following all that stuff
like they've the planet's been destroyed
um nick fury has like the orb used the
eye on nick fury but nick fury doesn't
know anything that he didn't know before
so that's really interesting like that i
thought was something kind of intriguing
so i'm i'm curious like what's going on
with nick fury but he always knows
everything he he does by the end of the
comic it doesn't really matter
nick fury had an uh had a backup plan in
case ultron came back from the future
and
he was hiding out in a bunker how do you
have that plan
he was hiding out he was hiding out in a
bunker waiting for the combined forces
of what was left of the avengers exactly
captain america and maybe some x-men to
find him if you did not think he knew
everything before then that moment i was
like yeah he's a cosmic entity
so so at this point what nick fury uh
thinks doesn't really matter and the
reason why is because it turns out that
bucky barnes the winter soldier is one
of the people who is part of the
original sin thing so he's going on with
like biblical verses and stuff like that
he leaves moon knight and gomorrah
trapped on the planet after destroying
the ship teleports back to where nick
fury's at and cuts off his head
so
yeah wait cuz big fairy's head he cuts
off nick fury's head he shoots him and
then he's fair he couldn't die
he cut his head off i mean nick fury can
be killed by conventional means he's
just ageless because of that formula
that he takes
but uh yeah he just doesn't age very
long but um but yeah he cut his head off
so that's kind of where we're at now
like he chopped off his head so that's
why that's why i say it may or may not
happen but i really hope
i am really hoping that original sin
leads to a reformation of the universal
church of truth and the magus because
that would be that would be so awesome
because i love you you said mad jim
jaspers again
and he's like i'm gonna have to look
into this guy yeah magazine don't make
me look into this guy
imagine jasper
yeah like did you read the deadpool time
though
yeah okay i i was so disappointed in
that because the whole issue had nothing
to do with original sin except black
robot lady finds out that deadpool's
daughter is still alive
but deadpool is so far away from her at
that point that he she can't even tell
him
yeah he's hanging out with that chick
that he married so i you know it's like
to me it was
the record david if you haven't been
following deadpool by the way about two
issues ago completely out of the blue he
married like the daughter of the devil
yeah she's cool
and they're they're they're holed up in
his his shitty ass apartment yep that's
all like
yeah just wanting to pick up some of the
newer deadpool stuff
yeah still wondering where this is gonna
go but
that's that's the thing about deadpool
deadpool is a character
i love deadpool when he's interacting
with other people i hate deadpool's solo
series it drives me nuts like he's just
really annoying it's just like crazy and
all over the place yeah it is it is i
mean it's really supposed to be like a
comedy release on a completely separate
note because i guess we're segueing from
deadpool or she'll send a deadpool but i
liked the direction they were taking
deadpool they got rid of the secondary
voice in his head they were giving him
more of a realistic grounded background
we found out more about him and the fact
that he did have a daughter and a wife
and all this other stuff and now and
then like immediately after having all
this really good good character
development and building deadpool in a
good direction they're like oh by the
way he just got married and now we're
going on crazy honeymoon adventures it's
like yeah
i don't know
i don't know see here's here's the
problem can you make up your mind is he
serious or are we just gonna do stupid
crazy [ __ ]
here's a problem with deadpool
deadpool's character was best when he
was wacky and zany and did crazy things
but he was part of a linear storyline he
was going to like when he was in x
factor
exactly the x factor and they had to go
kill the sun the the uh the apocalypse
clone guy that was great
i mean
okay now that was something that really
all right so let's let's talk about that
for a second so apocalypse all right
i'm i'm actually
really curious about what they're going
to do with him because right now he's a
little kid but he's showing signs that
he is going to become the apocalypse
from x factor the apocalypse he was
before he was reincarnated as a little
bit dude there's an entire 50-issue run
about what they're gonna do with it so
oh see i wasn't aware like i knew that
they were like x factor like 1 through
50 is all what are they gonna do with it
when it was before they rebooted it
again
okay but all right if i okay as i
understand it as i understand it right
now
he was reborn as a little kid they
killed him
and then he's back again and he's part
of the xavier institute but i thought
that there were there were basically
points where people had looked into his
future and saw that it's entirely
possible he could become this kind of
dark screwed up character like it was
before the entire wolverine and deadpool
x factor run um with phantom x and all
that is yes they killed him they decided
that they didn't like what they did
actually it was deadpool who didn't like
what he did because he got really
connected to the character they go into
the they go through it's a time travel
adventure basically if you kill them off
they go to the future find out the
future wasn't what they wanted it to be
because of this they go back in time
they stop themselves from killing him
then the brotherhood of evil mutants
kidnaps the kid and they try to turn him
back into apocalypse by telling him that
wolverine killed you and don't trust
them and they're just going to do it
again because basically they go remember
that they revert everything and then
they're like maybe we should have done
it it's the kid's still going to be
apocalypse this the issues kept
stretching out um and it ends with
they've decided to if they teach the kid
properly he's not going to become
apocalypse he can still do it but we
have an opportunity to teach him
properly to not be apocalypse
see i don't like that i want to see him
become apocalypse man i want to see
apocalypse come back my mind though is
one of the best endings to that thing
was deadpool being remorseful of the
fact that he had killed the kid because
it was deadpool they thought made the
actual kill and he didn't like the fact
that he killed a kid a kid who was
innocent and was not apocalypse no i
thought it wasn't deadpool i thought
deadpool was the one that refused to do
it and it was somebody else that killed
him instead i can't remember his name no
i could have sworn it was deadpool
because because that was part of his
thing in the ending because i remember i
i mean yeah for everybody who were off
that was like a 50 issue run so for the
record i i read it when it launched i
didn't read it like last week on a trade
so but as far as i can remember the
ending he's actually getting tortured
and he's like happy because he feels
like this is his redemption like his
punishment for what he did to the kid
okay and then the brotherhood of the
mutants are like look use your
apocalypse powers and just finish off
deadpool and deadpool's like look it's
okay if you do it i get it you know i i
deserve this and then the kid saves
deadpool and they have like a whole
moment they get off there and then after
that deadpool goes off and gets married
it's like he forget the kid
deadpool
yeah because i know that like kid
apocalypse is basically like an x-men
character or not he's tied into the
x-men comics now so
he's going on with the x-men and the
xavier institute and all that kind of
stuff they're trying to guide him to
make sure he doesn't become yeah and
then that's where the story got left off
and deadpool was it was part of deadpool
get it see that's what i don't like
about deadpool he goes through these
great character arcs and gets great
development and becomes a real character
and then he goes on a crazy adventure
killing the dead presidents who turned
into zombies and yeah yeah has a crazy
crazy character development oh by the
way he had a kid and he's remorseful for
what happened and they're using his
powers
and oh now we're going to go get married
to the the daughter of saiyan you know
that's that's why i say like i like
deadpool better when he is part of a
major storyline when he when it's not
his solo series because the solo series
is it's like it's like reading an acid
trip on comics you know but it seriously
looks like they sit down to go serious
story stupid story serious story it's a
stupid story oh did we just do serious
one okay they're stupid i don't know
what they do they just like
do a roll the dice and just whatever
happens i think maybe they're trying to
appeal to the
the deadpool fans from like the wade
runs and everything where he was just
super crazy and then they have to put
him in serious situations because they
put him in serious situations before
well okay they need to they need to go
back to at least having two deadpool
comics we kind of do because it always
pops up in a mini series but we need to
have the serious run deadpool because
even when he was on thunderbolts it was
horrible we need to have a serious run
deadpool on real adventures and then
just the over-the-top crazy zany one
give us both call it good you can even
make them interlinked but if you have
both stories running concurrently like
oh yeah he had to go stop the the end of
the world from happening with wolverine
and then he went on a crazy adventure
but that's in this comic and if you
don't care about it don't read it you
know yeah and the continuity stays the
same yeah right yeah i agree with that
yeah and then you could even refer to
each other you know oh deadpool heard
you were just a pirate with your parrot
buddy over on the caribbean islands oh
yeah i was but now we're gonna go stop
apocalypse
what they could do is they could have
that all what's going on in his head
they got rid of that they actually said
that the second voice in his head the
crazy voice was actually a crazy guy
with a healing factor and what happened
was when uh deadpool he got in a fight
with him and somebody chomped them both
up like a blunder and they merged into
one person
and then they actually had a comic where
he separates from the guy again
so the crazy voice is off on his own
yeah i don't know deadpool is just a
character that i mean my my subscribers
really wanted to see a deadpool video so
i was like okay i'll do a deadpool video
but i was like i'm not a big fan of
deadpool i've read like almost
everything on deadpool at this point i
have every trade for his run following
secret invasion where you find out that
deadpool's the one that actually stopped
it
yeah so yeah
all right so so here's here's ultimately
the question here's here's what i really
want to know with regards to what
they're going to do with the whole
original sin event yeah back to original
send
so where's this like where's it all
leading to because i have a very hard
time believing that the orb is the big
guy behind all this and we still don't
know where the second eye is that's the
question that nick fury dies asking is
where's the second eye like he's sitting
there trying to figure it out you know
where the second eye go and and that's
that's the question like one of my
subscribers made a really good point so
they think that there's like a bigger
hand here that the org
is a tool being used by somebody else
and i agree and i think that original
sin is going to end shitty
i don't think we're going to get any
core answers i think they're going to
give us a big reveal and it's going to
jump right into axis
because axis is kind of lined up to be
starting up right at the end of original
sin i feel like original sin is just
going to set up the next event
we're going to find out who's behind the
scenes how he got all the information
nick fury's gonna be revived or
something like that everyone's gonna
resolve their sins and now we're doing
axis
well it depends on what happens in axis
ii
like
i mean we know that wolverine will die
but we don't really know much more than
than that in terms of the access
storyline so here here's the thing like
i mean because if you remember like with
the house room you had house of m
everybody lost your powers
i mean that that could be but but
you had house of him and then you had
decimation
and then you had the messiah complex and
then you had the messiah war and then
you had the 12 lights and then you had
like all these events going on that were
that were concurrent they might be doing
the same thing with they might have like
a multi-series event with this crossover
that i i have no idea what the end
result is but i don't i don't know what
their end intention is because with the
end of days of or the end of house of m
we we saw pretty much all the mutants
gone so they basically rebooted the
entire mutant aspects
i don't think i don't want to see that
kind of thing happening they've already
done marvel now we already have a new
number one every other week with
somebody new who was it this week did
you see it in the comic book store
but
here's the thing though like the marvel
now event i mean as far as i'm concerned
i don't really care for it too much i
don't like seeing a reboot of the x-men
i mean i don't like seeing and so if i
don't know what actually i'm on the flip
side of this because dc is now doing the
same thing and
i kind of see where everyone's coming
from because david you're our new comic
book reader okay i bring you to the
comic book store right now and you're
like i like i like x-men i want to read
x-men and i'm like all right well here's
x-men
529
and you're going to be like
i'm like but it's a really good
character yeah you should totally read
it or you can walk in and we go hey look
there's the all new x-men number one
yeah you're almost guaranteed that this
is a brand new plot that you can follow
because dc is doing that now they've
stopped a lot of their concurrent books
we've got no they ended suicide squad
the end of t titans and literally with
only like a month break we're gonna get
teen titans number one and the new
suicide squad
and
but people are gonna jump on that
because you're gonna see a brand new
plot line you're like oh it's a number
one it's a totally new start even though
dude the teen titans pisses me off we
ended at a 31 and that story just got
worse and worse and worse and it ended
finally and they're like now we're doing
the new one and it's pretty much the
same team
well it's i mean it's also kind of about
time that model rebooted some stuff too
because like by the time we got around
to civil war in 2006 or whenever that
was
like we were on on spider-man vol 2
issue number 500 and such and such yeah
like it was time to go ahead and and you
know get a
they all spiderman
like is it all new origin stories no no
basically what that what they're doing
marvel now is and dc is now going in now
dc did the original reboot they started
new 52 before marvel now and they did
all new origin stories and everything
yeah but now what everyone's doing is
they're starting everything up at number
one and it's no origin stories they're
just it's a new plot go check it out you
can start at number one
basically yeah you could start with you
could start with all new x-men issue
number one having never read any of the
previous x-men comics and be able to go
from there because what you're going to
see is the original x-men team yep
you're going to see jean grey as uh as
marvel girl you're going to see cyclops
you're going to see iceman bobby drake
you're going to see the beast and you're
going to see archangel i mean that's
that's gonna that's the original x-men
lineup and you're gonna see them in all
new x-men now the stories will be
different they won't be the same way
they were in the original x-men lineup
but you could jump into those plots and
you're like oh it's safe i can start
from number one exactly i i think i
appreciate that more than what dc did
because what dc did was they basically
said ah all this old stuff that came out
in the last 30 years is no longer
relevant but see when dc did now see
here's the thing you know all new x-men
still references stuff that's happening
what dc did it you you literally could
go grab every number one and you
aren't missing anything right
you're literally at the beginning of
everything now that actually leads to
the next potential reboot you know i
think we've covered most of original sin
and this goes to the future's end
future's end is our dc event now what
futures end is because i doubt you guys
are reading it it's a weekly book that
is coming out and it's explaining what
is happening five years from now
five years from now we've been invaded
by earth two there's a there was a war
that happened half the super heroes died
uh brother i and omak came back um and
batman beyond
is all the way at the end of the entire
timeline and literally everybody's dead
so bruce wayne sends terry mcginnis from
batman beyond back in time to put the
timeline back on track but instead of
going to current nowadays dc which is
where he was supposed to go he ended up
at the futures end which is five years
ahead of us
so we see a lot of interest like the
first issue green arrow dies
huh because firestorm couldn't save them
um and a lot of things like that are
happening and this actually brings me to
a reboot there's a huge discussion that
in april dc is gonna jump because
apparently they're they've put out all
dc storylines will end in april and
they're going and what the assumption is
right now is that it's conveniently the
end of future's end and we're gonna jump
five years to how futures that ended
wow
so can i just fill in the middle at that
point well that's kind of what they did
with new 52 new 52 launched and when new
52 launched they were like it's a fresh
reboot but a lot of stuff happened in
the last five years a lot of your
favorite events still happened but it
was over the course of five years and
over the course of this three years
we've been finding out what happened in
that five year gap you know at what
point did blackest night happen at what
point did superman introduce himself to
the world when did wonder woman show up
that's and i kind of think they're going
to do that again they're going to get to
april and they're going to jump five
years to the end of this event and then
they're going to fill in the gaps again
and we're going to find out we oh the
dc's got a big mystery again we need to
know what happened you know batman will
have robin number eight well how did
that happen the flash will have wally
west instead how did that happen and
they'll start because what they did was
every year in september they do a 52
issue event and like it was the zero
year we explained what happened to year
one and then it was the following year
it was for it was uh it was first it was
the zero year then it was something else
and then it was the villains we found
all the villain histories and they
filled the gaps in with these big
multi-issue events
yeah so they might be doing that again
with future zen
all right so
a couple days ago i think um
benny asked a really good question
because you're talking about time travel
in your in your comic and benny thought
a really cool discussion is is what's
the thought of time travel in comic
books right i'm sorry not been a dave
asked that question you know what was
the thought about time travel and comic
books you know and and i don't know
it'll break everything
well i've been thinking about that but
don't do it until you need to wolverine
i mean everybody else
well it's just like a reset button yeah
it is what i look at it as is it's a way
to basically go back and say oh well
this event that didn't work out or fans
didn't like man didn't happen it's
always been that way it has always been
a big reset button uh dc uses it as dc
uses it as a the crisis as we call them
the infinite crisis the final crisis and
they just reset everything with time
travel or a multiverse collision either
one of those happens
um
marvel likes to do age of ultron you
know oh look we [ __ ] everything up
let's go back in time to fix it they
just time travel corrects everything
yeah and that's that's why i'm not a big
fan of time travel because i feel like
it takes away from the writers having to
write good stories that actually go
somewhere because if i mean let's say
for example you have this whole original
sin event and let's say that at the end
of this original sin event that
everybody knows everything that ever
happened to them and somehow they all
end up just progressively going more
insane we go back in time and divisional
sin i give up
yeah and and the the entire marvel the
entire marvel universe descends into
like total chaos where everybody's
killing everybody else for sins that
we're creating the best or whatever and
then
tony stark or somebody like that's like
well we can fix this by going back into
the past and read richard sends them
into the past that kind of thing is
that's that's the problem when writers
don't have the ability to send
characters into the past to fix things
then that means that they have to
introduce the beginning of a story they
have to fill the story with a compelling
event and then they have to bring it to
an end in a way that still leaves the
entire continuity intact and that's very
difficult to do when you have time
travel and i i think that's why age of
ultron didn't do well
because
age of ultron issue two wolverine goes
back in time you're like okay i know how
this is going to end
exactly exactly
it takes away all the fun yeah yeah and
that's kind of what i'm worried about
with features in we've seen the end of
the universe they've now gone back in
time they're going to correct things
things are going to go to hell in a
handbag we're going to get we got
anti-monitor here which implies we might
be getting another infinite crisis slash
final crisis you know we've got the time
travel supposedly we're going to jump
five years in the future but what the
hell is that going to do you know
there's so many time travel situations
and a matter of fact that's exactly what
happened that dude that that is what
they did in dc
oh we've really made everything
convoluted and nobody wants to read our
books anymore hey flash go back in time
and fix everything
new universe
yeah that's that's just that it's one of
the things that really irks me because
like i said it takes away from a
compelling story because the writers at
the end of the day are always like well
if it doesn't work out we can just send
somebody in the past and fix it and
that's it done and done and if you
notice that each universe seems to have
its time travel guy yeah
every every single universe that you
come across well like in dc it's always
the flash if it's a time travel event
the flash is involved and in marvel even
though it makes no sense wolverine's
always
involved i mean it's
i mean so yeah it will be another
character in marvel who has time
traveled more than wolverine
and the entire fantastic four team
doesn't count because that's like that's
like a weekend jaunt for them hey we're
gonna go
okay like bishop or cable
i don't i don't mean because they've
just kind of gone back time travel all
the time
yeah cable cable does bishop i don't i
don't think he only jumps when needed
gable cable does like a weekend vacation
oh i'm just going to check out the
bahamas
with bishop see bishop's character was
really kind of cool because if you guys
remember bishop jumped back into the
past um when he was first introduced in
x-men and then he was part of the x-men
he stayed with the x-men for quite some
time he was part of the x-men run now in
the messiah stories messiah complex
messiah wars him and cable and hope
summers are doing like this cat and
mouse game like you've got cable and
hope summers progressively jumping to
different locations throughout time and
bishop is chasing them trying to kill
hope summers so that aspect of time
travel i think it's cool because it's
not there to fix anything it's simply
just there to provide a compelling story
and it really was a cool background
instead of being at the x-mansion for
this entire discussion we're going
through time and that's cool i mean i'm
more referring to we always have our
time fixer guy
oh really he's our time bixer guy they
always just they always come with an
excuse and almost because oh wolverine
will survive anything send him back in
time
well that's that's the thing i mean
that's that's why
when it comes to time traveling it could
be a great tool who's going to go back
in time
i mean with time travel it's a great
tool to move a story forward but
the problem is is when it's abused i
mean you know like like i was telling
dave earlier about the uh the further
adventures of uh cyclops in phoenix that
gives you the entire backstory of
sinister and and cyclops and phoenix end
up in the past with uh with sinister so
you see when apocalypse first approaches
nathaniel essex and he grants them all
kinds of powers you know says i will
give you whatever you want so on and so
forth and he turns them into sinister
you know you see like all these really
cool stories going on but it's not a
time travel is not used to fix things
time travel is used as a means to really
just kind of explain a compelling story
and so then that aspect i don't have a
problem with time travel when it's used
that way i have a problem with time
travel you know like benny said when
they say well the story is kind of out
of control things are really convoluted
nobody can keep up so let's just send
somebody into the past and fix it so
that's that's really kind of like i mean
you don't like what they did for the new
52 reboot how do you feel about and
we can close out this discussion after
this because how long time's going on
and
kind of moving on but how do you feel
about what what their support i mean
this is all speculation right now but
what dc's doing now
where we're gonna jump five years we're
not correcting anything we're gonna go
ahead and then we're gonna tell you what
you missed
see that's not something that i'm upset
about like that's i mean okay it's like
like a comparable example was like age
of ultron like nick fury and them jumped
into the future all right so they could
try to destroy ultron i mean technically
it would have changed the past but it
was cool because it didn't matter
because they all ended up dying anyway
but
you know with
if i understand what you're saying with
what they're doing with the whole
futures and like we're going to have we
start out in the past they jump five
years in the future and they show us the
future and then we're going to cover the
past five years over the course of
however long this this goes on for right
well what they're gonna do is supposedly
when this event ends in april all comics
are going to move forward from the
five-year jump okay and then we're going
to see special events that explain what
you miss like there's going to be a
bunch of mysteries that come up like how
did this happen why is this going on and
to me that's that's cool because i i
mean i think that people always like to
see some kind of like dystopian future
when when it comes to comic books it
just seems cool or to just see like
future events and then say what happened
back then you know like i think people
have that that natural cure like okay
for example like it's totally off topic
from comics but i downloaded uh or i
didn't download i i legally attained a
copy of uh aliens the director's cut oh
did you handle them
yes it's it's a legally obtained copy it
was on sale for free
really low price it was it was close to
zero dollars as close as you can get to
zero dollars and uh
i was uh i was watching you know
watching the whole thing go down
nonetheless they arrive at hadley's hope
the place on lv 426 and the whole place
is totally ruined and totally destroyed
for the most part
and and no one really knows what the
heck happened but people always want to
know they're like what what actually
took place at hadley's hope if they
released a movie and they said here's
what happened in hadley's hope people
would buy and they would want to see it
because you have the events of alien
where ridley or where ripley leaves the
planet more or less escapes in her ship
then you have aliens where it's you know
30 years later or whatever it is and
people are living on lv 426 and now
they're all dead and everybody wants to
know what happened in between to me with
this whole futures end thing in dc it's
a lot of the same way you're going to
have this event that ends ended with a
whole new or not new 52 the um
uh forever evil storyline and they
basically rebooted everything and then
you then they jump forward five years
and they say now here's what things are
going to look like in five years now
people want to know what happened over
the course of that five years that's
exactly what's happening right now with
the weekly book the forever evo yeah for
futures and it has a weekly book right
now and it basically it just
supposedly the weekly book is going to
end
when the events in the main book kind of
get more current with that is what's
going on it's kind of weird the way
they're doing it but they're already
giving you mysteries uh there's a lot of
boring crap going on in that weekly book
but one big mystery going on is
supposedly red robin died
tim drake died again or not again he
this the tim drake didn't
jason todd did you know but tim drake
died but he didn't die
the papers and everything in the futures
and events say that he died and he
actually just retired because he had a
falling out with batman and is
apparently a bartender and he keeps
implying that there was some major thing
that happened between him and batman but
we haven't figured out what it is yet as
a matter of fact i don't think we've
seen batman in the new in the future zen
story yet we don't even know what he
looks like
but that conflict would be something
that will be explained but you know that
went on between the five years of
the beginning of future what happened in
this five years that tim drake died and
then but didn't die and that basically
is hiding out as a bartender
okay that sounds interesting yeah okay
so in in the in the effort to progress
our podcast forward
all right so give me the rundown on what
you think about what's going on with the
new super girl because i don't really
know anything about what's going on with
her this is the live history lesson on
your heroes last week we did the orb
this week is going to be a dc character
and i'm going to cover supergirl now the
reason i'm covering supergirl is because
she's going through
finally a major change
uh supergirl in general
so supergirl this time around actually
came up as interesting supergirl in the
new 52 the story is that she has been
orbiting the sun the whole time and this
has overcharged her supposedly more
powerful than superman she shows up she
can't speak english she's 17 year old
girl can't speak english it has more
power than superman knocks him around
the world and at first it's an
interesting storyline because you have
this alien on the planet it's an alien
out of water story line it's not a alien
trying to blend in with us it's a what
the hell happened where's krypton how do
i get home
and they dragged that story out for like
25 issues
like at first it was really cool then it
was now she's whining then it was while
she's just an angry teenager and that's
i don't know if this was intended
eventually but here's where the
interesting part comes in supergirl as
it turns out is she's she is the same
thing kyle is now older than her
superman's old in her she's still his
cousin she was babysitting him she's
only 17. she has more power than him and
she can't control it because she didn't
learn how to use it and she can't speak
english i think by now she's kind of
picked up on it but when the the first
20 issues she was always speaking
kryptonian so only cal could even speak
to her um
what they've done with her now
is her rage of being her planet being
destroyed she had to kill her love she
fell in love with hell she had to kill
him off um the fact that no one
understands her everyone's trying to
kill her because they don't understand
her earth so they always try to pick
fights to their like the army and
everything get out of metropolis that
kind of thing
um
we also have the red rings in the
universe and a red ring will go out and
seek someone filled with great rage well
they've been building up her to the
point where oh she got so mad she
punched lobo in half like punched him
and it broke wow
basically like she she was finally
coming to terms with everything the plot
line just before this and she went up to
this little space station thing that her
and superman hang out on lobo shows up
to do something there and lobo's like
look i'm the last of my race you're the
last of your race we should talk i can
help you out i can tell you i know what
you're going through and she's like you
don't know anything and boom punches him
like through a bunch of crap breaks his
limbs off he's destroyed
wow yeah
damn
and then she flees from that because she
just punched lobo into pieces he
recovers he's fine
but still i mean that was something that
not even superman was able to do was
physically destroy lobo yeah like i'm
not aware that he was ever able to do
that no i don't i don't think superman
ever did that either the new lobo is not
as strong as the old lobo but that's the
story for another day um but bracey
breaks him apart she leaves because
she's just killed a man you know he just
kind of recovers and goes oh wow that
girl sucks
and a red ring finds her and a red ring
finds somebody who is filled with great
rage and then we have this entire
storyline
which started out really good
where supergirl became a red lantern she
the ring founder and the way the red
lanterns work is you are
all of your rage goes to the surface you
can't even talk when you first get a
ring
so you have a insanely overraged
supergirl who now has the powers of a
red ring plus her kryptonian powers
destroying earth going nuts it took
everybody to stop her wow okay
and this is where i think it got
interesting because we took what was
just an angsty teenager and we did a
giant crossover event
where she
becomes a red lantern and the story i'm
holding all the issues for it right here
i think i'm missing one out of this
little batch but it's a six issue
storyline about her getting the ring and
then um the red lanterns can
drop you into the red blood and then you
become sane again
and they do that and she has finally
found a place of people who understand
her it's a whole bunch of refugees from
planets people filled with rage and that
the new super girl right now is still a
red lantern now
the problem i have with the story line
and where they've gone with this is
we've got 30 issues building up her
anger and her rage and how much she no
one understands her and she's had to
kill everybody and be poisoned by krypto
kryptonite and all kinds of crazy stuff
and all of it all believe it boils down
to how angry can we make her we finally
culminated accumulated whatever i call
me i can't say the word we finally
accumulated accumulated into all of that
rage into her getting a ring and now
being a red lantern and fighting on guy
gardner's red lantern team against
atrocitus and the other red lanterns
and apparently she's gonna lose it too
in two issues
lose the ring yeah like the ring the
ring can't even be reserved it can't
even be removed without a blue ring
which right now they've been destroyed
in green lantern lore but somehow
an issue 34 she loses the ring and goes
to help superman with the doomed
infection thing i'd be curious to see
how they do that
i
and but
and here's it's almost like they don't
know what to do with supergirl
and that and that's kind of what i'm a
little issue about here new 52 supergirl
is just a rage machine and they don't
really seem to know what to do with her
other than we've got superman with boobs
because i mean they've given her a ring
and
once they made her scene again she just
started whining again
i mean that's now she's like oh no one
understands me and now i can't take the
ring off and i'll feel the rage maybe i
can work with the red lanterns ah
i mean i don't i don't mean to come off
you know as like a you know it's like
anti-chick or anything but
like she doesn't really seem to serve a
purpose as best as i can tell whenever
it was that i had i had read about
supergirl or just kind of looking at
supergirl in general because she didn't
see what some people don't aren't aware
of and this is something that i've
actually recently discovered because i'm
doing the researcher jessica drew most
of these
girl
spider woman spider girl super girl
they were created for the sole purpose
of copyright
yeah that's it was the exact same way
they were made because the because
marvel and dc were worried that if they
didn't make these characters the
opposing group would take it
yeah
that's exactly that was that was the
entirety of their of their being and
then they discovered hey we've got girls
we got boobs let's put them in cute
outfits and make them go be the
sidekicks basically
i mean that was a whole basis for uh for
she-hulk when when the incredible hulk
tv show was out in the 70s or whenever
it was and it was garnering like a ton
of popularity they just made she-hulk
for the purpose of being able to say
she's our character actually belongs to
us and i think that's the problem that
we've run into a super girl supergirl is
an amazing character she's she's this
okay i mean the history of supergirl and
especially the new 52 right now is she
got pushed off the planet just like how
lel did but the difference is calallen's
been on earth this entire time learned
his powers learned how to deal with
humans every every storyline of
supergirl is she arrives at 18 19.
she orbits the sun or she got lost in
space something happened where she
wasn't here even in smallville that's
how it happened
um and that is the core history of
supergirl she's always the late person
to the party and now she's supposed to
be older than her nephew or her cousin
but now he's older than her and instead
of being the wise one she's now just the
whiny teenager and they've always done
that with her
um now there is a bit of a history where
she died and then an alien took over her
appearance and everything but they've
never really done anything outside of
whiny supergirl and i'm slightly upset
because the whole purpose of this
learning your universe stuff we're
trying to do right now is i wanted to
explain the red daughter of krypton
that's what they're calling this series
and this was finally something that they
could do with supergirl and i i do i
highly recommend these this series of
books to anybody who wants to kind of
learn a little bit about supergirl
yeah and my complaint is we're already
going to shoot it down you're finally
giving her something that's worth some
kind of character development outside of
oh my god no one understands me i belong
in the oc you know
we're finally going beyond that and
we're going to remove it well let's see
here's the thing though here's a
question you have to ask like i mean
as far as i can tell she really
seems to be on like demigod power at
this point i mean she's got the power of
lanterns of the lantern yep and she's
got all of her kryptonian powers yep i
mean comment on that like every freaking
issue
yeah we've got a kryptonian with a red
ring everyone's screwed
yeah i mean that's just like that's
that's stupid
they're they're all they're constantly
going like don't piss her off
she can't control it
i mean it's it's you know it's it's it's
that's why they're removing it because
as much as this does finally develop her
character in a good direction this is an
insane amount of power to give her
i mean i mean this is this is like the
equivalent of having emma frost who has
all of her powers she has powerful and
she's powerful enough to rival charles
xavier and she has the same powers as
the incredible hulk it's just it's
really stupid and it's just incredibly
powerful
now she has heat vision the ability to
fly the ability to super here super cold
breath you know she can punch through
superman right she blew up lobo with a
punch she's stronger than superman
because of over charging okay
not only is she basically superman times
two
but now she has a red ring and a red
ring gives you the ability to spew
napalm
and go in a raging fueled massive you
can spew napalm that is so strong it
will eat a green lantern's ring it will
infect his ring
wow
so now she can do that and make uh
constructs because they've discovered
the red landers have discovered how to
make constructs
um so she can make constructs she can do
everything basically she can do
everything the green lantern can do
everything superman can do and spew many
palm right now
well see that's that's the thing like i
think it says something about her
character if the only way for them to
create her in a compelling way is to
make her so wildly overpowerful
that she is you know that she's she
there's really no one that can stop her
single-handedly aside from somebody that
exists beyond you know the simple
universe and exists in multiple
universes or something let me show you
this one
you got guy gardner and superman trying
to stop her
and it's just not yeah see that that's
what i'm talking about man i mean you
know it's it's cool you know but
the i think the thing about when it
comes to someone like supergirl is you
know and when you look at marvel
somebody like she-hulk is a perfect
example of three's a crowd you know for
example during the world war hulk story
line like she-hulk confronts the
incredible hulk with everybody else when
they're in new york you know and new
york is in a
incredible hoax and a rage and she was
like you need to stop this and you know
he tells her he's like go away and she
talks on for like three or four
paragraphs and he was like now and she
won't leave and so he just grabs her
face and slams it into the ground and
that's that she is not the incredible
[ __ ] she's not nearly as strong and she
really just isn't nearly as important as
he is i mean civil war is really
important that's it i think that's how
they started off with the new supergirl
take though i mean because
she's always been the backdoor character
to superman never as strong always his
cousin always basically just she's like
it's just like basically a damsel
limited stress form and i think with the
new 52 reboot they decided to give her
more power than him to give her more
character
and i just i don't think that went in
the direction they were intending
yeah and so now they give her the red
ring but see they could they could leave
it with her for a while we have a gr we
have a kryptonian with a green ring
yeah we do um jasmine whatever he's been
gone forever he literally just came back
he literally just came back
um
yacht i think is it
dave you're looking bored over there man
this is a guy who well this is it saddam
yat is basically a guy from the same
universe and i'll link you the image
afterwards you can put it in whatever
you want um but he's a guy from the same
like milky way the galaxy as superman
but yeah if he has all the same powers
as superman
but he gets a green lantern ring
he just got reintroduced into the new 52
universe so we're going to see where
that goes but so it's not unheard of to
have someone with so much goddamn power
yeah but that's the problem is you can't
have a person with so much power that
rivals virtually all the other
superheroes and you can fight them all
at the same time and have them appear
all the time like apocalypse is a
perfect example apocalypse demonstrated
on multiple occasions that he could
fight off the combined forces of x-force
the x-men and the avengers at the same
time like by himself you know like all
at one time so
you know you can't have them up here all
the time because then it would it would
take away from the from the front of it
so i mean i i would hope that supergirl
you know would be able to be to have the
green lantern you know the lantern ring
taken away from her or just simply lose
her abilities and keep the lantern ring
whatever you know but from what you said
they're going to take the ring away from
her so
i would like to see her which is which
is one of the issues i have in dc right
now they they spoil their own plot lines
but in the new justice league united
she's in there and she doesn't have the
ring
okay you're like okay well this isn't
going to last much longer then because
we already have other story lines where
she's back to normal
so i would like to see her i mean even
though they take a ring away like write
her in a way to where she can be a good
and important character and
and be interesting you know because if
she's written in such a way where the
only way she's interesting is when she's
physically challenging everybody because
she's just so ridiculously overpowered
then that really just kind of tells you
that the writers just aren't really
writing her in a compelling way because
if a character has to be crazy powerful
in order to be interesting
then they're not you know what you're
right though cause supergirl i was about
ready to drop the book until they
announced this event and this event is
really good and i actually liked the way
it ended it ended with superman being
like he's like look you can't remove the
ring guy gardner i'm i'm putting it on
you you keep her in check she's like
okay i'm gonna learn to be a red lantern
and guy gardner's like all right you're
in my team and that's how it ended it
didn't end with a we're gonna fix it it
was you're a red lantern there is no fix
there's three books of her raging out of
control and three books of them dealing
with it and then just now you're on the
team
i'm interested to see what direction
that goes in but
anyway that'll be discussion for another
time guys we're gonna bring this podcast
to an end because we've been going on
for like almost two hours i think an
hour and a half or
in so something like that
and a half
actually i want to i want to ask two
things here i want you people i want to
get people's opinions on the thing i
want first off i'd like you guys to
leave us any questions you have about
anything because we're going to start
doing we'll start doing like a mailbag q
a thing towards the end of this podcast
uh answer any questions we'll we'll if
you want to throw random stuff out there
like why does mad jim jasper's why is
rob so obsessed with him put it out
there we'll see what's up you know
you know
if you want to know what dave has been
reading for the weekly poll then go
ahead and let him know ask him let us
know any question we will answer them
all and if it's if it's completely
stupid and out of place then we'll we'll
do like a special out of place question
episode or something i don't know but
um
and secondly i wanted to know because we
we're we're kind of trying to put this
on an outline or schedule or
do you want us to limit the topics do
you want us to make this like a two
topic 30 minute thing do you like four
topics 40 minutes thing do you like hour
and a half do you want to just to go
until rom has to run off because dave
and i aren't going anywhere so
like
how long do you have these to go for
because i mean for we could do a
four-hour podcast probably i think we
did none of us that have a voice at the
end of it but
yeah it'd be a long plot ah the four
hour podcast we're just trying to see
what you guys recommend and rob took my
thunder and has already started putting
it up on itunes and you did you did i
was i was gonna do that and you took my
thunder i did so um we are located on
itunes rob a link down below so will i
and uh other than that i don't have
anything else to say on the outro do you
uh no that's it i mean civil wars come
in on monday so oh yeah you're looking
outside every at the end of every
episode we should both announce what's
coming out on our channel so the next
week yeah yeah yeah so civil war will be
there on monday civil war is going to be
a little lengthy guys it's it's a seven
part series overall it's got 123 comics
including tie-ins so this will probably
be a multi-week event it'll take a while
for me to get through it all but uh
after that i have no idea i'm gonna do a
two minute video on it
well it's easy just to see if i can
explain the entirety of the entirety of
the civil war in two minutes uh actually
i can i can do it in about 10 seconds
i mean you could ready ready ready all
right all right it's a superhero
registration act everybody goes on to
different signs of the superhero
registration act one side the superhero
says you either join us and join with
shield or you don't or you don't join us
and you get to keep doing what you're
doing the teams separate captain america
versus iron man iron man becomes a dick
kills captain america civil war over
i mean as a kill captain america but
thanks for ruining the entire civil war
well i'm just i'm gonna do an
explanation on it
i just i just do house of him yeah i
just saved a couple weeks ages and you
just successfully compressed it
into 10 seconds 20 seconds wow 5 000
page i'm going to miss in 10 seconds
ladies and gentlemen it's got to be some
kind of a record all right overall comic
story in this week i'm going to be doing
the uh forever evil arkham war that'll
come out today or tomorrow um i'm also
going to give you a know your know your
universe on spider woman for the record
did either one of you know that
technically the ultimate universe spider
woman is a transsexual version of peter
parker no
what
you're gonna you're gonna have to watch
my video
but i'm just letting you know right now
i because i don't know much about the
ultimate universe so i know jessica drew
and i'm like well everybody keeps asking
who she is i'm gonna do a video on her
and i'm going through it i'm like
ultimate universe jessica drew is a
carbon copy clone of spider-man
with a with uh the x chromosome it like
wow so so the ultimate version of
spider-man is a or spider woman's a
[ __ ] yes
spider woman in the open universe has
all of peter parker's memories it's
literally
the way she looks at life is literally
rob you woke up tomorrow and you had
boobs my god
but i'm going to go more into that video
this week so
all right well i i yeah i definitely
want to check that out
i'm actually debating titling it jessica
drew the transsexual you didn't know
existed
all right dave give us the rundown on
what your plans are about your channel
oh i'm doing that and i'm also going to
do the final storyline finally so what i
would like to do is
i would uh like to
kind of introduce people to good books
that i read during when i was first
getting into comics
uh
and if they're a good idea to read or
not when you are getting into comics
um so like even new books that i'm
reading i can kind of you know
tie into that
uh if they're good to read
or if they're like age of apocalypse and
you have to read two or three x-men
books before you read it
yeah that's the problem with final
crisis that's i'm writing this script to
it i'm halfway through the script i'm
not even on the actual book yet
crazy man yeah final traits i read that
that was my third justice league book oh
god i still don't i still don't
understand it like
no one understands
i i i did a test recording yesterday how
do you finish the script and the first
three minutes is explaining what happens
before final crisis
i'm like oh so i got to explain the new
god war and who the hell darkseid is and
what is the anti-life equation and oh my
god
all right guys so we're going to go
ahead and bring this podcast to an end
um again be sure to check out benny's
channel and uh if you guys are coming
from vinnie's channel check out my
channel and when dave
gets his channel online whenever that
happens to be
then check this out so and please please
leave comments down below with questions
and what you guys think of this podcast
so we can steer to the direction that
you guys want us to go in uh we don't
want to be doing something that you guys
all hate and has no views and then it's
just the three of us talking because we
can do that without recording so we want
to know what you want to see so please
let us know down below also topic ideas
we love topic ideas i mean
we have plenty we can come up with but
give us more
yes man you guys have questions we have
answers so we will talk about whatever
you guys are interested in but any event
uh yeah well if nobody has anything else
we'll catch you guys later have a good
one excelsior
you